nothing competes with I was in a
restaurant in America couple weeks ago
and the way it did this and I could hear
him even when he went away I was it with
Jane right and I just every time I went
can't that can't that maybe atomic bomb
right [ __ ] that God so so I'm worried
about the atomic bomb [ __ ] do that
yeah there's a few things that annoy me
why do people have to do that why no one
ever told him it was on a plane words
and some room was typing that annoyed me
it's hair right
she was typing but she had bangles so
the [ __ ] now was that a circus had
come to [ __ ] town
I wanna go sick just take the bangles
off you know I think I know it's me
I know it's it no I didn't say anything
I didn't say that that's the other thing
I thought what I don't want to anymore I
said I can be obsessed right if there's
if there's like two people and one of
them's doing all the talking that annoys
me at the voice that does that as well
cutting through the bar cutting through
the bar yeah well I said to him you know
I'm [ __ ] miles away I can hear
everything they spoke saying oh you know
I mean oh god everything annoys me and
this there's no reason for this
everyone's you know I've got an annoying
laugh but I'm going I'll go into a
restaurant a bar and I'll suddenly just
see someone going straight back out
happy for no reason why are you clapping
[Applause]